listen I'm thrilled to talk to you both
about this movie it's I mean Ryan's
heard me say this many times it's
fantastic uh if you make more of these
I'll be the happiest person
um so before getting into Glass Onion um
I like you both have made um some great
films and for for someone hypothetically
they've never seen anything you've done
what is the first thing you want them
watching and why Wow I used to have this
thing there was a couple of movies that
I did back in the day
um
and when Blockbusters were still a thing
um I used to go to Blockbusters another
saw it on the Shelf I would grab it and
throw it under account
I know it was like not going to make a
huge difference but at least one person
didn't see the movie it would be a good
thing so um
[Laughter]
um so does that yeah
I don't know uh don't
um yeah no you go ahead
I mean brick my first movie I think is
like a fun like and that's just because
it's an entry point yeah why not yeah
I'll say I'll say brick yeah because
also because my grandfather invested in
Brick so everybody that clicks rents on
it still he he gets three cents so it
gives three pennies to my grandfather oh
wow again you'll have done the world
some good good yeah I don't know yeah I
I mean it's it's a um
it's a movie I did Called Love is the
devil which was about Francis Bacon the
painter
um which is odd weird
um and uh most people probably won't get
it but it's uh it's a it's one of those
movies which I one of the reasons I got
into making films because
movies should Challenge and they should
they should you know sometimes make make
you uncomfortable and that does both
thank you uh for answering um for both
of you I am so curious I love learning
about the behind the scenes of the
making of a film and I was trying to
think of something to ask you guys um
for the both Knives Out films which shot
ended up being the toughest to pull off
uh and why well it's not I mean we're
we're not doing any kind of like crazy
insane
shots in either of these I think this is
so slightly broader but the difficult
challenge for both of them for me was
the scenes where you have nine people in
a room together talking to each other
and that just I mean I I went to and
back and study directors who I think are
Master is at staging groups of people in
the frame like Steven Spielberg is the
modern master of how the stage is seen
and and keep it interesting and create
shapes with groups of people in the
frame or Michael Curtis or Orson Welles
they're directors who very dynamically
use foreground mid-ground background
with staging people and and keep it
Dynamic and interesting so um so for me
I would I would say it's kind of a cheat
but there's no one shot but the scenes
where it's tons of people is a very fun
challenge but it was the biggest
challenge Daniel which sequence or which
sequence for you ended up being
um the challenging one if there was one
that was more difficult than the others
well thankfully that stuff he's talking
about I don't have to think about
but it's your problem
um but uh I understand it and I
understand the kind of the trauma or not
trauma but the kind of it's a it's a
it's it's complicated and he does it
beautifully so
um there's no worries there
um I don't know we have this whole thing
I I in the first one
um you know when I got the script
there's the new moon which is the and
and the kind of the explanation and the
long speeches and I said to Ryan I said
I don't want to split these up um I'd
like to shoot them
as long as a lot go as long as possible
I don't want to keep cutting into them
uh for a number of reasons I didn't want
I didn't want
because a lot goes to voice over and I
was really concerned in my head I have a
like this ridiculous ear like I can
always hear when there's added dialogue
and always it's just that's my it's it's
my it's a kind of curse when you're
watching a movie because it can take me
out of the movie and I wanted it to be
as consistent as possible I wanted him
to be able to cut away from me you keep
using my voice and it fulfilled all one
performance so I learned it as one piece
and we shot it like long long takes
until the magnet until the the the card
ran out you know at times just to just
so that it could have a continuity to it
and we did the same with this one
um so as hard as it was it's just you
know line learning is just a pony trick
it's everybody said how do you you know
people ask me about acting they said how
do you learn the lines that's the job
the hard bit is acting it so thankfully
he was around to keep an eye on me I
agree with you about ADR it takes me out
as well
um gentlemen I have to stop I'm just
gonna say again congrats and I really
you hope you're making a bunch more of
these thanks Dave
thank you